We are taking calls via discord at
David Pakman dotcom slash discord.
Let's go to Sarah. And I believe it's
Hamburg, Germany. Is that right, Sarah?
Hi, yes, it is in Germany. Yeah, hi, how are you?
I believe that there's some cities of Hamburg
in the US, which is why I asked.
Yeah, there's one in New York and.
Right. At least at least one.
Exactly. Know what's on your mind.
Yeah, I was wondering. I heard that, um,
December 14th, there is going to be another
vote for the Electoral College.
Well, let me explain that, Sarah. That's great
that you're asking this. So, you know, there's
all this talk about the media doesn't get to call
an election, but that's this is the situation.
Every year. States have a certain amount
of time to certify the election.
And then this year, it's December
14th that the electors actually vote and
that's when the election becomes official.
That's the case every year.
And that is absolutely true.
OK, so are they required because I'm hearing
that they're not actually required to
go with the popular vote of their state and they
could just vote technically however they want. So
technically, let's say they could vote for Trump.
That is absolutely true. This is something
called a faithless elector. And the
reason that this was something that
is allowed constitutionally is so that ultimately
electors have the opportunity to correct.
Imagine that a total madman were elected like
Donald Trump in twenty sixteen electors could
have said, we have to exercise judgment and
not cast our ballot in this way. And Sarah,
if you just put me on speaker, make sure to take
us off, because we're starting to get feedback of
my own voice. And in twenty sixteen, in fact,
two electors were faithless. Donald Trump won
three hundred and six electoral votes, but only
three hundred and four actually went with him.
So that could happen. Never in history has it
reversed the results of an election. And if
Joe Biden has two hundred and ninety or three
hundred and six electoral votes, I'm confident
that there will not be enough faithless
electors to turn the election results to Trump.
Right, just yeah, I mean, I
understand being faithful,
but just to confirm this is a possibility.
It is. It ain't technically it is always
a possibility in every election. Yes.
I mean, what. Wow. OK, what do you
think happens then? Let's say that
happens just hypothetically. I'm saying
that would. But what happens? What happens?
I don't know. I don't know if there's
any recourse. And so, I mean, it's a
great question. I don't know the answer to that.
All right, well, I guess we'll just have to see.
Yes, we will. I don't. I don't. But
again, I don't it's not going to happen.
There's not you know, Trump would need 20
faithless electors or 36 if Joe Biden wins
Georgia, that's not going to happen. All right,
well, let's hope for the best. Let's all right,
Sarah, thank you very much. Great to have
calls from our friends in in Germany.